today is the end of our journey in the  fight for justice  justice has been served and we are  deeply saddened that this has happened  to James  and that our young people are being  stabbed on our streets  James was fortunate to have survived  however he has been left with severe  life-changing injuries  I want to thank all the officers the  barristers and the people who has worked  behind the scenes  for their hard work dedication to bring  those people to Justice  this should not have happened  and I urge people who carry knives  to stop  [Music]  please stop  the trauma cause to my nephew and my  family mean we are now living with the  impact of knife violence forever